[Music]
gabriel is with us in los angeles hi
gabriel how are you
hi christy hi dave how you guys doing
great man what's up
hey so i had a question for you dave um
so i have
i'm on baby step 2 right now i have
about
12 000 in my savings and
right now at the moment i know i got to
pay off all my debt and i have two
car payments one of one of the cars
doesn't work though the engine went out
so it's going to cost me thousands of
dollars to fix it
so my question is i know i heard you i
might have been a couple weeks back
saying that
a zero credit score is fine if you have
cash because already that's paid off
so my question was do i let this car go
that doesn't work
and let them take it even though it's
going to mess with my credit
or do i pay it off
that's my question okay so what do you
owe
on the car that works the car that works
is
i still a lot i still about twenty four
thousand that's barely
what do you make i make forty thousand a
year
have you got that car for sale yet
the one that doesn't work the one that
does work you can't afford it
no okay no so what do you got like a 600
car payment right uh
it's all 490. yeah okay
and and you make 40k this is a car you
can't afford
this is what's killing you so the car
that doesn't work
what do you owe on it i owe about 10.
what is it it's a hyundai tucson
what year 15.
in the engine blue
yes um it's kind of a long story i don't
i mean well i'm just trying to ascertain
what to do is the en
you said the engine's bad what does that
mean i mean you dropped a rod
it's a complete meltdown or
it has to have a new engine or it just
needs heads put on i mean what's the
situation
no it needs a new engine okay
all right uh
so that car fixed is probably worth 12
isn't it
uh yeah okay
um that's my guess i'm not too yeah well
probably worth at least what you owe on
it and the one that's
that you owe 24 on what do you think
it's worth
um i don't know i'd say maybe like
15. how old are you
i'm 32. your family in the area
uh yeah actually i'm actually married
with three kids in the fourth on the way
like your parents are around your uncles
or aunts are around or anything like
that
um yeah they're all around okay so
here's what i would tell you today all
right um
you're gonna use some of the twelve
thousand dollars to get a used
engine from a salvage yard a junkyard
that a local mechanic not a dealer
puts in this car you can do that for two
to three thousand dollars
you're gonna fix that car because if you
turn it in right now it's worth a
thousand dollars they're gonna sue you
for the other nine thousand dollars
and you're gonna have a repo that is not
a plan
not when you can spend a little bit of
your cash fix the car
and then we're either gonna drive that
car or we're going to sell it
because we're selling the other one
you don't need a 24 000 car when you
make 40 a year
right that's about broke people stuff
right there so
we got to get rid of that and you may
have to use some of your 12 000 to get
rid of that 24 000
card because you're probably upside down
on it
right so if you write a check for two or
three thousand and get out of that car
and i check for two or three thousand
and get out of the other car
you still got six thousand dollars left
in your savings account
and um you're either going to use that
to go buy a car for cash to drive
or you're going to drive the ten
thousand dollar car and start working
your way to paying it off
right after you put a used engine in it
so here's the deal somebody totaled a
car just like that
and the car they total only had 20 000
miles on it
and so the engine that's sitting in that
totaled car and that salvage yard is a
perfectly good engine
and it is the cheapest way to put an
engine in a used car
a used engine in a used car
and you can do that in the los angeles
area the reason i was asking about
family in the area
is my my uh advice is kind of old school
redneck advice and i was hoping one of
your
your daddy or your uncle or somebody
actually had turned a wrench at some
point in their life and would know
how to pull off what i'm talking about
with a good local mechanic
i'm not suggesting they actually do the
engine change out
but the point is that somebody can get
their head around this because dude
if you just walk away from this you're
gonna get sued for nine thousand dollars
and you're still gonna be sitting on
twenty four thousand our car you can't
afford
right that's not a plan that's five
years from today that's you're gonna
look back and go
both of those things were dumb and if
you
to fix this in the next four or five
months the way i'm talking about
uh you would have no car payments or
very little car payment
gabriel i hope you really do it you
sound a little sleepy to me i hope you
really do it you've got a baby on the
way a fourth baby by the way
i hope you really do it get yourself out
of this mess yeah
there's not the problem is you know
larry burkett
used to say and he was a guy in the
christian world that taught on money
he said whatever time it takes you to
get into a mess it usually takes you
about the same time to get out
and i have learned that it did to
disagree with that it usually does take
you about half the time
okay so if it took you three years to
make the mess it might take you a year
and a half to get out okay but it
usually doesn't take you three years to
get out
and in his case he's either going to
continue
making messes yeah by being half asleep
right
and turning this car in and continuing
to try to drive a 24 000 car he can't
afford
right because he's sleep deprived with a
house full of kids i don't know but
um lori's going to throw his shoulders
back
straighten that spine out and step into
this thing and go i'm going to short
i'm going to go into a short term
intense
amount of inconvenience and pain yeah
to limit my long-term damage well it's
like you always talk about you can
wander into debt you cannot wander out
people get into a mess
gradually incrementally by degrees
accidentally no one few people go
headlong into like i really want to mess
with my life no one looks at something
and goes that's really stupid i'm going
to do it i can't wait to do it i can't
wait no
unless they're doing drugs i mean no one
just does it right
no it's gradual and so it takes you
three years of gradual
missteps and then you look over it is a
really dumb idea but you just thought it
was smart
at least you thought it was smart you
know i mean i've done a lot of stuff in
i've been an enthusiastic ignoramus
several times right
same sure uh but then when you get
when you decide what you're going to do
to fix it you get an intensity
about you that lessens the time it takes
to get out that's what you talk about
with the gazelle intensity that's what
you talk about the
you know year and a half versus three
years you have an intensity and a drive
and
a fire under you to fix it well like
it's like you know we're
talking about running this morning but
but you're a big time runner
and you've done a lot more half
marathons or marathons than i've done
but uh but it's amazing to me that you
can run
uh 12 and a half miles
over for me that's a two-hour yeah
arrangement right
and i'm turning the corner and after
running jogging whatever
for two and a half hours or for two
hours and 10 minutes or five minutes or
whatever
i turn the corner and i can still sprint
yeah yeah and my mind is printing but i
mean
at least i can run fast you know i can
i've still got something left in the
tank because i can see the finish line
that's right that's right and and you
know you go
i'm gonna shave just a few more seconds
off of this deal yeah
and i'm gonna bust that line right there
and i'm gonna bust into it yeah
i'm not gonna stop and walk across the
line yeah you see people with this
paying off their debt they actually end
up doing it quicker than they thought
their goal because they get that
intensity
last six months because they started to
believe that's right they kick it in
and there's something that goes with
that it's pretty powerful you guys
so hey personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20
had knowledge most people know what to
do but for 30 years we've been
convincing them to do it around here
it's called the ramsay show